hace más de una semana empezarán los
incendios forestales en la región de
gironda al suroeste de Francia los
estragos de la destrucción se pueden ver
desde el aire kilómetros de árboles
quemados demuestran el riesgo al que
estuvo expuesta la vida de muchas
personas por la devastación las llamas
casi tocan las puertas de muchas casas
aunque las llamas comenzaron a
extinguirse el humor Recuerda que esta
batalla aún no ha terminado
cosas han mejorado pero solo porque las
cosas van mejor no significa que esta
batalla haya terminado los juegos
Todavía están aquí y siguen Ardiendo
en el transcurso de la última semana los
incendios se han extendido por toda la
región los bomberos han actuado
rápidamente y las llamas dejaron de
crecer
decididos a reducir el riesgo de nuevas
conflagraciones los servicios de
emergencias siguen regando los campus
completamente secos y es que la
situación requiere de múltiples riegos
para que la temperatura de los campus
baje y no haya nuevos incendios la
temperatura del suelo el aire y los
vientos hacen que el suelo se seque
rápidamente Así que hacemos múltiples
turnos tenemos numerosos motores
dedicados a que se enfoquen en los
puntos críticos a pesar de que los
bomberos lucharon durante 10 días más de
20.000 hectáreas de bosque han sido
quemadas